Bienvenido a la presentación de multiplicación de expresiones, déjame poner un problema.
Dice multiplica "x" más 2, "x" más 2 por  "x" más 3
puede parecer un problema extraño pero en realidad ya sabes hacerlo.
Simplemente hay que aplicar la ley distributiva mira, si tuviéramos
a "a" por "x" más 3
entonces pues aplicando la ley distributiva, simplemente nos quedaría  "a" por "x" más...
deja pongo lo de naranja primero...
entonces sería "a" por "x" más "a" por 3, "a" por 3 se ve un poco
raro pero lo podemos poner como 3a, pero bueno el chiste es que este "a"
multiplica a cada uno de estos términos,
estamos haciendo lo mismo aquí solo que ahora "a"
es "x" más 2 es toda la expresión "x" más 2 entonces, vamos a ver cómo nos quedaría, nos quedaría "x" más 2
multiplicado por  "x",  más  "x" más 2
multiplicado por 3 ¿Va?
Entonces parece un poco complicado pero no lo es
simplemente tenemos que darnos cuenta que estamos haciendo lo mismo que de este lado
pero ahora el "x" más 2 juega el papel de "a".
Bueno ya que hicimos este primer paso el problema ya es muy directo,
otra vez tenemos que aplicar la ley distributiva,
distributiva con cada uno de estos términos entonces ¿Qué nos quedaría?
Déjame quedarme nada más con el color verde
nos quedaría "x" por "x" es "x"
cuadrada luego 2 por "x" es 2x más 2x más 3 por "x" es 3x
y luego más 2 por 3 que es 6, ya casi terminamos.
Ahora hay que juntar estos términos que son términos similares
porque tienen la misma potencia de "x" y entonces nos quedaría "x" al cuadrado más
2 más 3 son 5x más 6.
Muy bien entonces ahí está este problema y simplemente la idea es distribuir este "x" más 2
en cada uno de estos términos y después ya se hace muy directo. Vamos a hacer otros problemas más.
Entonces imagínate que queremos multiplicar
5x más 9
5x más 9 con 4x menos 2, 4x menos 2.
Mismísima idea distribuimos el 5x más 9
5x más 9
primero con este 4x, por 4x
y luego hay que
sumar el 5x más 9
5x más 9 multiplicado por el -2, por -2 vamos a ver, qué nos queda. Me pasó a color verde
5x por 4x. Lo hacemos aquí abajito 5x por 4x pues esto es lo mismo que 5 por 4
por "x" por "x"
que es 20x cuadrada ¿Si? 5 por 4 es 20, "x" por "x" es "x" cuadrada entonces, nos queda
20x cuadrada más 4 por 9 es 36 más 36x más
-2 ¡Ah!  Entonces aquí va con menos entonces es -2 por 5 es -10x
-2 por 9, -10 y 8 ¿Va? ¿Muy bien?.
Simplificamos juntando términos similares y nos queda 20x cuadrada
36 menos 10 es 26 más 26
26x menos 12 ¿Muy bien? Vamos a hacer un ejemplo más.
Déjame pasar aquí abajo, voy a cambiar de colores
para para que no esté tan monótono entonces, siguiente problema
2x más "y", 2x más "y" multiplicado
por 3x más 2y.
Creo que ya vimos de qué se trata, ya nada más voy a usar un color.
Entonces voy a distribuir este 2x más "y" pero voy a poner primero ahora estos para variar tantito.
Entonces distribuyendo me queda 3x por 2x más "y"
es este por este, más 2y por 2x más "y".
Sale ¿Ok? Desarrollamos este y este 3x por 2x, pues 3 por 2 es 6, "x" por "x" es "x" cuadrada
más 3 veces "x" por "y", que se puede escribir como 3xy, xy es lo mismo que "x" por "y"
más 2y por 2x, 2 por 2 es 4,  "y" por "x" es yx
más 2y cuadrada, 2y por "y" es 2y cuadrada.
¿Muy bien? Ahora ¿éste se podrá simplificar? Pues si
yx y xy es exactamente lo mismo entonces, podemos juntar estos 2 términos y nos queda 6x cuadrada
más 3 más 7xy juntando estos 2, 3con 4 es  7
más 2 "y" cuadrada o bien también pudimos haberlo escrito poniendo la "y" primero o sea como 6x cuadrada
más 7yx más 2y cuadrada
¿Va? Es exactamente lo mismo espero que esta idea no te confunda
pero bueno vamos a hacer un último problema.
Rápidamente porque éste está interesante.
Y dice tenemos que encontrar 2x más 2
2x más 2 al cuadrado.
Ahora hay que resistir la tentación de elevar cada uno de estos al cuadrado y sumarlos,
porque si no no estaríamos haciendo las cosas bien ¿Va?
Entonces para hacer las cosas bien tenemos que
reescribir éste cuadrado como producto de dos cosas.
Algo al cuadrado es ese algo 2x más 2 por sí mismo 2x más 2.
Entonces mismísima idea, distribuimos este 2x más 2 en cada uno de estos términos
y nos quedan 2x multiplicado por
2x más 2
2x por 2x más 2, más 2 veces 2x más 2.
Vamos a simplificar
bueno desarrollar, y ahorita simplificamos.
2x por 2x, 2 por 2 es 4, "x" por"x" es "x" cuadrada 2x por 2
es 4x más 4x más
2 por 2x es 4x, 4x y finalmente hay que sumar 2 por 2 que es 4 ¿Muy bien?.
Simplificamos podemos juntar estos dos términos, nos quedaría 4x cuadrada más 8x más 4 ¿Ok?
Entonces 4x cuadrada más 8x más 4 es 2x más 2 al cuadrado .
Creo que con estos ejemplos ya estás listo para intentar algunos problemas de multiplicar expresiones nivel 1.